hi everybody my name is norm johansson I
work for Amazon Web Services back in
Seattle and today we're going to talk
about anybody serverless with dotnet
core so the talk is not going to be too
much about what is service we're just
going to focus mostly on the 80 bits
implementation because I know there's
already a lot of sessions at the
conference already on server lists so
we're going to go over is what are the
common editing services that you will
use when you're going to do a service
application then show off what are the
business to do tooling to get started
with dotnet core and lambda and then
look at the command-line tooling for
users who are not doing Visual Studio or
want to hook up this to their CI system
and once we get an understanding of the
tooling and how that works we're going
to take a look at what a real lab
scenario might look like so Edith has
like over a hundred services right now
which is pretty remarkable because I've
been in a dress for seven years and when
I started there was fifteen I believe
there were so had that much growth in
that amount of time and so we're not
going to cover all those services so I'm
just going to focus right now on just
what are the ones that you're going to
most likely work with when you start
working with service apps on AWS so the
first service in if you heard anything
about server list computing out there
you've probably heard of Oedipus lambda
that is the compute part of the service
architecture this is the service that's
actually going to run your code it has a
design of its event triggered and its
event based scaling this means unlike
traditional applications where you have
a collection of virtual machines that
are running your application and you get
monitoring to see we need to add remove
stuff in this world there is no compute
power initially added to your service
application it's when those events come
in is when the land was going to decide
hey you need compute power and go
allocate that up and this means your
scaling is more of like it's scaled by
events so if you suddenly get a thousand
events coming with all once then land is
going to go make sure you have that
compute power available to you and then
when those functions are done does that
compute power would go away so you would
only be paying for when your functions
actually run and not that idle time
so Lamba supports nodejs Python Java and
last November we added dotnet core
support Amazon API gateway this is the
front end of the ATIS service
architecture so this is what's going to
expose your lambda functions out to web
that's like Web API and it has other
features as well like managing
authentication versioning monitoring and
more now a to visit identity access
management this isn't strictly a service
service but it's one you're going to use
regardless because this is the service
that manages your credentials and your
permissions so in lambdas world is
you're going to be using API side in the
nexus management or IM to basically give
permissions to your code to access other
other eight of your services and you do
that by defining a role and you allow
lamda to assume that role which will
allow it to create credentials and on
that role you can have a number of
policies applied to it which is what
gives that lamda permission to access s3
or whatever service you want to use and
so with a bit confirmation you're going
to be using this you will most likely
use the service as your service
application but gets more sophisticated
because you're going to find that you're
going to have other ATS resources you're
connecting to you got to keep track of
all those events that you're going to
set up so with cloud formation you can
define your whole ADA's architecture as
a template file which is usually a JSON
file that can be parameterised and that
allows you to just say hey Confirmation
go create me this 80 bit of stack and it
will go and create all those resources
and set up all those events for you as a
unit and this could be like your test
back your dev stack or whatever and then
when you're done with it you can just
say delete this back and it clears out
all those resources so it's a good way
of keeping track of all those connection
points for your service application so
those are the four main services we're
going to talk about today and so to
recap we have lambda 4 compute API
gateway is our front-end a to the site
of the access management's going to be
managing our permissions and
CloudFormation
so we can automate our ad bus
architecture now the easiest way to get
started writing nightcore lambda
functions is with visual studio and our
editors toolkit for visual studio we
support 2017 which you can solve in the
visual studio gallery as well as visual
studio 2015 for 15 you need to download
that from our website it comes down as
an MSI and 15 doesn't have done that
core support in it by default so you'll
need to be installed a duck or tooling
into them now I'm going to live
dangerously and do some live demos
mostly to make up for my lack and
PowerPoint skills so we'll just go right
into that so if you've never used our ad
basics of Visual Studio first thing we
might notice is we have this window over
here we call database Explorer which
allows you to manage a lot of the common
services developers use right inside the
studio the ones that are managing data
or messaging or in lambda in this case
and you can also up at the top you can
register profiles this is basically you
can have a number of atreus accounts
that you might want to have inside the
studio you add new ones pushing the new
button and you add in your ADA screwed
in chills a nativist credentials are an
access key ID and a secret access key
and what those are used for is
underneath the toolkit as well as in
your own applications when you're using
the eight weeks SDK Fernet it's going to
use those credentials to sign the
request to AWS which is how we do s
education if you ever can't find this
view you can just go and reviews and
there's a twist Explorer right there
now it gets ours landed we need to
create a project we go to file new
project and under the visual c-sharp
node we have a twist lambda and we
basically have two different project
templates out there with the option of
creating a test the lambda project is
basically when you want to write a
single function and you're going to work
with the lambda services directly you're
going to set up the connection endpoints
all that for you and the service
application is when you're going to work
with CloudFormation to deploy maybe a
number of lambda functions together as
well as your other ATIS resources
so we can get a better idea of how lime
to work so we're going to do the lambda
project right now we're going to call
that image tagger and we'll say okay so
once you do that you're going to get a
choice of blueprints it's basically
things to help you get started if you
want to just go completely from scratch
you can choose the empty function which
has the minimal amount of boilerplate on
there the simple ones down here have the
extra boilerplate on there for dealing
with events coming from those services
and we have a couple that are more like
tutorial ones we're going to take a look
at this detect image label which is what
it does is it's a blueprint that's going
to be listing for pictures being
uploaded to an s3 bucket s3 is our
object storage and it's going to go use
our image recognition service to find
out what's in that picture what labels
are in there and then tag our object
with those labels so let's say finish
and we created our test project and
we've got our lambda project here now
what a lambda project is is it is really
just a it is a just a class library
targeting netkar up one oh we do only
support net collab net core 100 that is
currently designated as the LCS version
of.net core and lambda always has a
policy with all of the runtimes to
support the long-term supported version
of that runtime so if we look at our
code here regular C sharp code here we
got a couple constructors let's look at
those so the first one is just the empty
constructor which is creating a couple
service clients from the adrià 50k for
net and you notice when we create these
clients we're not passing any
credentials information or what region
we want to connect to and we can do that
because when we deploy this lambda
function we're going to assign an IM
rolled through that lambda function in
the sdk in its logic was looking for
credentials we'll look to see am i
running in an environment that has an IM
role and if so grab the credentials for
that role and make the request of that
similar with the read
it will detect that I am running in EU
s1 and we'll use that there I could
override all that but at the constructor
if I won and but it's really best just
to use the configuration coming from the
environment the rest of the stuff is the
way this blueprint is set up is when we
detect labels we can say we only want to
accept labels with a minimum confidence
of that label I think the default in
here is 70% but when you deploy a lambda
function you can set environment
variables so in the environment where we
could override with that confidence
level is the other constructor here is
passing in the clients because this is
what's used by the test project since
the test projects not running in a land
environment it's up to that test project
to construct those clients and so here
is our actual function here this is what
lambda is going to give a call takes in
an s3 event the lambda context is going
to give you information about the
running environment and this is an async
method and so just like I'll see sharp
code if you're doing an async method you
want to be sure to always return by cat
asks don't do async void what land was
doing is it's going to call this message
and say hey you returned by cat ask I'll
wait to that test complete to know when
you're done
so if we just did void it would think
that you were done right away so we live
through our records we're going to use
this is the image image recognition
service we're going to go detect some
labels then we're going to go construct
a collection of tags s3 tags and then
use the s3 client to put those tags on
there so overall it's a fairly simple
code but it's an easy way just to tie
these two services together now the
other file we have in here is called the
APIs lambda tools default flow so this
is a file the blueprint or the blueprint
put in there to help set up a lot of
those initial values when you deploy the
function we're going to look at a couple
of them a function handlers probably
most important one because this strings
will identify for lambda
what is that c-sharp function I want to
call in my class library so it's
identifying the assembly the type name
and the actual function in that class to
call the other thing that I think is
worth pointing out is memory size I
wanted to call that out because it's
it's more than just memory size the way
I'll always look at this property is
more of it's a slider on the amount of
compute power you want to give to your
lambda function because what lambda does
is as you increase the memory that also
scales how much CPU and network power is
added to your lambda function so with
those I'll set let's take a look at how
we deploy it to do that we right-click
on a project and we say published AWS
bring up our wizard and you can see that
are those values already set because it
came from that file so we just need to
put in a function name we'll call it
image tagger and on the second screen
the most important thing we got to do is
this is where we're going to set the I
am role this is what's going to give
permissions for our function because our
function has to access our s3 bucket and
it's got to be able to access image
recognition service so we could define a
role with those policies now for me
right now I've already set up an
existing role that we're going to use I
could create one with some of the pre
Ken policies that we have out there or
if you have some policies that you've
already set up on your count I would be
able to create those we're just going to
select that one and here's where I could
set an environment variable so if I
wanted to override that minimum
confidence level I could pass in a value
there we're not just going to be upload
and so this is basically doing a dotnet
published that the CLI zipping that up
and telling lambda go to go create a
lambda function and so we bring up this
view of the lambda function which is
coming from natives Explorer you can see
image tagger there and we can do a few
things in here we can modify the
configuration of it we can also just do
a test invoke right from here there's
some sample requests of what you might
send to s3
for example here's the requests what is
here's an example request would look
like coming from s3 where it identified
the bucket that you want to say there
was a new object created and object
those those don't exist so I'm gonna go
ahead personal anyways this is not going
to work though because those objects
don't exist but you can see how right
from here you could modify that file to
something really does exist to test how
things work in production and you can
see here's the error of not being able
to exit set objects what that also
allows me to do is in the log view we
can get a list of the logs so we can see
what really happened in here so here are
some of those print statements if I
showed that but all of the console
rights in here is will be forwarded to
the cloud watch logs that are associated
with that so that's I get your log
messages there and you can see there's
the stack trace so now we have our
lambda function deployed it's got
permission to access the service but now
what we need to do is we need to
actually hook this up to our s3 bucket
so we can do that in the event sources
tab this has some of the services that
you can connect with s2 with lambda a
lot of the other services you need to go
to their web console or use their SDKs
to do that connection up so here we'll
say add s3 is already picked you do need
to pick a bucket that's in the same
region as you so I happen to have one
code EU s1 pre-fit prefix and suffix you
can use to sort of filter which objects
you want to get events for we'll say
okay
and so now they are connected so when we
add objects to that s3 bucket this will
cause our lambda function to be invoked
we can test that by if we go over to s3
and the toolkit
here's that bucket here I'll open up its
view I don't have any objects in there
currently so let's copy some images of
my family in there upload those so now
as these are being uploaded this is
going to then trigger those events to a
from F from s3 to lambda to go do that
logic we had so they're connected
without actually running any service to
do that so that's uploaded we should see
by now and if we refresh the logs I'm
betting there is it doing some of its
work of getting those tags and get a
better view of that if we go back over
here and let's see how well this service
did so here it is my daughter playing on
the beach see how what did they think of
that so on that we can properties and go
to tag and we can see that she is a
human there's water she's on the beach
she's having a good time there try this
one
anybody would take a guess where this is
a picture of anyone yes I did convince
the family go to New Zealand this year
and I don't think my wife appreciated
doing all the Lord of the Rings things
but it was fun
so what did we do on the Shire there I
said there was a chair we got a pumpkin
up there in the garden furniture squash
and vegetables it didn't pick the hobbit
holes but that is kind of a custom case
so right so there you go this is how you
can easily write these landed functions
and hook up these services to do more
interesting things without even having
to run servers with it
so to recap get the toolkit to try
things out 2017 get it from the gallery
15 you'd be get it from our website you
can use the toolkit to manager ativ
credentials you can also use the tilt it
to get blueprints to get started you do
need to have the class library Targa net
core f1o and then the toolkit we can
deploy functions and we have that
default file to help us with a lot of
the initial values for deployment so
let's take a look at the command line
because you know the dotnet core we can
do things more than just I do visual
studio so let's bring up a console here
so the first thing we want to be able to
do is we want to create a project and in
visual studio right we had all those
blueprints to get started well it turns
out when they g8 the.net core tooling
last winter they added support and that
dotnet new command to add new templates
to that and we've added things to this
so if we say dotnet new - I for install
I can say Amazon Landa templates
: : star color poem star going to use
the latest version that's going to
install that new get package that we
have and put all those blueprints that
we had in Visual Studio right there on
the dotnet new command which I already
have done so I'm going to run it again
so if we say dotnet new you can see
there's all those lines of functions
right here so we can do these anywhere
we are I'm going to keep this demo
simple so I'm just going to use that
empty function blueprint we can get help
on that if we say dotnet new when the
empty function help and this is telling
you that you can pass optionally in the
profile that create profile if you come
to the studio or the region
or both and what that's going to do is
it's going to inject in that default
file is going to create it's going to
set those up for you so when you do the
later deployment from the command line
you don't have to keep entering those in
over and over again
so let's scrape this dotnet new Landa
empty function I have to spell it
correctly
profile use my norm J profile region is
EU West one and I'll name this demo funk
that's right yeah
project is created so let's go into that
directory we can go use video code and
see what we got here
so here we get we got our test project
so we can see how we can write some
integration or unit tests and we have
our code the empty function is very
basic l it is it's just trying to give
you some code to get started with it's
just doing a two upper on the string
passed in so you could take that and go
do whatever you want with it so what we
need to do now is well how do we deploy
this function and what we did is if you
look in the CS proj file we installed a
dotnet CLI tool reference to the Amazon
lambda tools so this is going to add
commands into the donut CLI so we can
manage the deployment right from there
in fact it's the same code that we do in
there that we do in Visual Studio and so
that menu item in Visual Studio to say
whether to publisher nut how we choose
to show that is do we look to see it's
just a dotnet core project and does it
have this dependency if it has this
dependency up then we assume this must
be something you want to deploy at
lambda and so we'll add that menu item
there okay so let's deploy it so let's
go to our function and we need to
restore references so it's going to pull
in our tooling in there and now if we
say dotnet lambda help you can see these
are the commands that have now been
added to the CLI this first section here
is dealing with just the lambda projects
like we saw we just did in Visual Studio
the second set is for the server this
left when you're doing deployment with
CloudFormation and the bottom two are
sort of utility ones for when you want
to maybe hook this up to your CI system
and you want to just use this to get
everything packaged up right for lambda
alright so then to deploy that we would
do dotnet
deploy function alright let's look to
see what that takes if we say help do
that takes a fair amount of parameters
and that's where that default file comes
in really handy because most of this is
already set for us the only thing we
really have to set at this point is what
is the function name and what is the I
am role that we want to use so we'll say
dotnet land deploy function and I'll
call it demo funk and I don't remember
my role so if you don't enter the role
on the command line it's going to prompt
you for that as you're doing the
deployment you can see here what roles I
want to use and I'm going to say I'm
going to do that same role I did in the
previous demo and there it is it's
created so we could stop see if we did
that now land list functions you can see
there's our two functions the one we did
in the previous demo and then we just
did we can also do some testing of the
function right here so we know this
function just does a two uppers all it
does so if we say dotnet lambda invoke
function demo func and we pass in a
payload we'll say hello in DC say return
so this will run that function just like
that sort of test view in the toolkit we
can run it here on the command line you
can see we've got a cloud two upper
function though now you might be
wondering why did it take 800
milliseconds just to do a two upper on
that the reason was this was the first
time this function was invoked so that's
when lambda had to then go and allocate
the compute power needed for this
function download the function from s3
and start up the dotnet runtime if I
have to run it again with all that stuff
already warmed up you can see from
lemons point of view it was much faster
there okay so that is the CLI so again
to use a CLI you want to do a dotnet new
to install the templates right there I
give you all the blueprints of inverter
studio and
you've done it new to create your
projects and then you do done at lambda
deploy function to start pulling it
right from the command line okay so my
real life scenario which immediately the
demo didn't get is fully completed as I
had my ambitions for was an app called
pollster what this app is is it's a
website for customers to put up polls
and everyone can vote on those polls so
my requirements are is I need a website
that everyone can access hit vote on
those polls every poll has a start and
end time so I'm going to need sort of a
state machine for these polls and again
I'm being serve lists I want to do no
servers with this application so to do
this we're going to introduce a couple
more services some of these you might
have heard Amazon DynamoDB
this is our manage no sequel database
service and for us what we need to do is
we need to create two tables out of that
one is a table to store our definitions
for the polls and the other one is to
storing the list of the current active
polls and a nice feature identity has is
you can enable streams on that which
sends out events of your items being
changed in your tables or new items
being added and as you can guess with
those events you can hook up lambdas and
then process those events and so we can
use those to start our workflow on that
the other new service we're going to
talk is a diva's step functions and this
allows us to define a state machine that
basically in our case the state machine
is fairly simplistic it's just a
scheduling of I want to I want to stake
when I want to schedule it how long do I
wait till I activate it and then I got
to deactivate it after a certain amount
of time and each one of those states
where there's work to do a logical tasks
we can say we hit the state in the in
the state machine go call a lambda
function to do that work so again we can
keep with sub being servlet for doing
all that work now one of the interesting
things that we've been doing lately with
our dotnet core tooling is we be doing
work to be able to run a spinet core
apps run
on top of lambda I'm not saying this is
the right solution for every duck neck
or Lander project but if you happen to
really like writing your web apps using
a spirit core or you're not ready to
learn in your programming model you can
do this this way because it allows you
to use the same program model we already
know we can just run it locally in is
and test it all there and then when
we're happy we can just go deploy that
to lambda there are cons are because we
are bringing a larger framework there's
a little bit more to be initialized
during the startup so you want to be
very careful about what it is in that
startup
yes that you're really in doing because
that is going to be invoked during the
initial code start a gap of this
function now it's not done for every
single one of executions basically what
happens is when lambda starts up that
first code the first time it's executing
that function in that compute
environment if we initialize the Holy
Spirit core framework so that the next
request will be fast also razor views
are not supported doing this so we need
an alternative framework for our client
code so what I'm doing is I'm doing
everything in angular for that that
let's go into another demo here
so here is poster again this looks like
a regular exponent core application we
have controllers here like we've seen
many other places there's controllers
for getting poles and the feeds and
voting on those we have our program CS
down here which starting up kestrel
likely that so that way we can easily
just do f5 and we can run this
application locally we can do our local
development test it there and see what
it looks like see how we doing so here
it is where should I take the kids for
vacation so for I have like Norway
optical might make a go to Norway I
think the kids want to go to Disneyland
see how that works out for them ok
to get this to work and lambda what I've
done is I added that nougat package I
talked about earlier and I have a new
class in here called lambda entry the
name is arbitrary you can call whatever
you want but it extends from this class
api gateway proxy function which this
has one method you need to override
which is via knit method which looks a
lot what we saw in the program cs where
you need to set up the content routes
today what is the startup class but
instead of saying use kestrel and is we
have to say use api gateway because
that's going to be our web server in
this case now the actual lambda function
comes from the base class it is this
function handler async that's actually
going to be called that's the only code
changes we actually did to this
application to make it run on lambda
everything else is the same as your own
agent record and the other things we
have in here is under workflow this is
my state machine test so these are my
series of lambda functions that I'm
going to use for those the states in my
state machine these are all fairly
simple ones they're going to take in a
pull state object and it's going to grab
that pole ID find out how long till we
should schedule it or set that second
still active on that and then we're
going to turn that back and that's what
the the work state machine is going to
use to figure out how long to wait and
that logic sort is similar for the
activate and the deactivate we have
these other lambda functions in there
and we also this is going to use more
parts so this is why we're not just
deploying straight to lambda we're going
to use this as a service app deploying
with a CloudFormation template which is
what this service template is here and
if you look in that default file we
specified template is service template
so now when we deploy it the wizard is
going to be a little different in fact
let's deploy it first because it takes a
couple minutes for it to come online and
then we'll talk about what's in that
template you can see the wizard is
simpler all we really have to do now in
the wizard is specify what is the name
of the cloud formation staff and what is
the s3 bucket that we want to use to
store our applicate our compiled
application bits when we do this
deployment if I had parameterize the
template there would be a next button in
there for me to enter those parameters
but for this example I didn't
parameterize them so we'll just go ahead
and publish that it's going to do the
similar thing it's going to compile the
app zip it all up send it up to s3 and
then we're going to basically tell
CloudFormation
go and create a this CloudFormation
stack with these resources so that in a
second is going to bring up the view I
drink some water and here is the cloud
formation stack view coming from the
Explorer you can see it here and this is
going to start streaming in the events
of these various resources coming online
for us so while that's going let's take
a look at the server list template so
template has you can define parameters I
didn't in this case and then you have
your collection of resources so let's
look at that so I mentioned I needed two
tables so here is my definitions table
that's being created and my active
polled collection and down when we
download we table it since it's a no
sequel there's no schema all we need to
do is define what is the key and I
mentioned that we can enable streams on
this so that's where this is it so this
is going to enable streams that we can
hook up a lambda function to capture
when new polls are created and start
that workflow execution and there's my
active poll and then we have the aether
net core function so this is really the
lambda function that represents the
whole is going to core a part of this
it's type of service function that's
sort of a meta resource because what
it's going to do is it's going to create
more than just a lambda function with a
it's going to also set up our API
gateway as well that's this event
section here so the events is going to
say hook this up to type API which means
a pack gateway and
normally a lot of times what you'll see
is that when people create a service
application they'll use a tie gate
weight and define all of their end
points in their rest application but in
this case what we've done is we're just
saying send all requests to our lambda
function because since this is an
eight-minute court application we're
going to rely on a spinet core to write
to route to the right controllers for us
and for any HTTP method the other thing
is going on here is we can pass
environment variables in so we're going
to pass in the names of those dynami
tables that just got created as part of
this template so because initially I
just have my two tables that I was using
locally but now I suspect I probably
have a couple more that just got created
based off my cloud formation template
here's my state machine so this is
saying use this role to run the state
machine I should mentioned also and that
lambda function is when we specified the
role it used so we have a two roles
we're using here's the role the state
machine has so that's giving our state
machine access to invoke our lambda
function because by default you never
have access to things in a diversity
always in a BAS you always have to tell
it what you're allowing things to do
nothing's going to act on your behalf
unless you say you're it's okay and then
there's a definition string which you
might wondering why is that blank the
reason that is blank is we have added a
little extra tooling in our done a
tooling so that in our default file we
can say with this substitution replace
the content of that with by this JSON
path with this contents of the file the
reason we did this is that I could
define that state machine in its own
separate file and not have to try to
define it in an escape JSON document
inside of a string so if we look at that
state machine and say here's all those
states alright we've got our schedule
state
which is going to call that lambda and
that return back that property set of
seconds tool active so that's going to
wait that long
let me go to activate wait again and so
on
again this is a fairly simple one we
could do more complicated things but we
didn't need to in this example so then
here's our collection of defining those
lambda functions for each of them of
those we're going to use inside our
state machine so there's that schedule
to schedule tasks lambda function active
tasks like wait to ask deactivate you
might be wondering why are all these
code blocks empty and if is empty a as
well for the ethernet core function the
reason is when I write this file I don't
know where the code is going to be
because the code was uploaded as part of
our deployment you saw that was that
first step in that deployment wizard
what did the wizard doing is it first
uploads everything to s3 then read this
template file and goes and autofills and
all those properties to where i just put
two bits F so you're not having to
manage that and then the last will
resource we have here is this is that
Dyna T V processor this is the function
that is going to go listen for events
coming off of my done and V table and so
I can start those workflow executions so
here I'm passing those environment
variables of again those tables that I'm
using and also now the state machine
that just got created and then in the
events section I'm saying this is hooked
up to down RGB to this stream this is
the stream coming from that pool
definitions table so here I've defined
know all a lady's resources in this file
that I can just deploy as one unit the
last thing that we need to talk about is
permissions or because we have to give
access to these database services they
don't have that by default so here's
that role I defined for state machine
which basically says here that Atos step
functions is allowed to assume this role
when it's working with our state machine
and it has access to to call the
operation in
function so it's the only thing state
machine can do or state step functions
can do on our behalf and the other role
here is the one we're going to use for
all of our lambda functions so that's
why we're saying that this can be
assumed by lambda so these are all the
permissions our lambda function can do
and there are a couple ways you can do
set up policies you can use manage
policies which are there's either you
can create your own policies that you
can share in your account or there's
policies that database services provide
so here is a manage policy that the
lambda team provides which basically is
going to be giving me access to right to
cloud watch logs but now I also want
access to dendy B as well so this first
means open this little wider here first
rule here saying I don't expend want all
the crud operations for Dyna TV for only
those two tables so there's no way that
my land of function can affect anything
going in any other tables and I need to
give access to the stream be able to
access the stream so you can get those
events and the last thing we need to do
is we have to give permissions to start
the execution of our workflow and that's
it now I'm betting our stack is complete
it really took about I think it takes
about a little less than 2 minutes let's
see my computers on Seattle time here
but so it started at 9:00 11:00 a.m. in
Seattle and finish at 913 so to create
that all that second all those resources
took about 2 minutes to do now I created
brand-new tables for this application so
I don't currently have any poles in my
application so to help this out I did
create one of my web controllers is one
just for adding sample data which is
going to go read in this JSON file
sample poles so let's just go ahead and
run that I'll use postman for that I'm
not going to do an update in the middle
of a demo and so we'll say API sample
data as a post
send that so this is going to go and add
those tables to my definitions table
which is then going to trigger off
events coming off the stream which that
Danity stream processor is going to find
and kick off the executions of the local
executions which then step functions is
then going to say well let's start the
flow of that and start scheduling those
pass our pulse so if I go into the web
console your step functions the first
one was from a different practice that
it earlier today but so this is the one
I just created you can see here's the
executions for the three poles I just
created and they're all currently and
that sort of wait to deactivate because
the way I set up the sample data is I
wanted them scheduled for now if you see
if it took in is it's got that pole ID
which it was 0 seconds would activate
and now it's going to stay there for
that many seconds 12,000 seconds or so
so there's all that hooked up so now if
we go to the website
you can see we have now deployed our
service application using all those
moving pieces together as one
CloudFormation template and we can start
using it so I can say I am currently
using Windows Chewbacca is the unsung
hero of Star Wars movie where should I
go in Norway I am NOT going to try to
pronounce any of these names but I
thought I would go to this valley to do
some hiking I don't know how to say that
name though there we go so there is our
service application all deployed
together to CloudFormation template
without using any servers for this ok
how am i doing on time I have a little
extra time here so the one thing that I
was think about this last night while
going through this again that's
bothering me about this is we are using
lambda functions to deliver the static
content right because this site has CSS
it has JavaScript it's bringing those
anchors and using lambda functions to
bring down static content is probably
not the best use of Latin functions
that's what we have as 3/4 for using
bringing down static content so like I
said this guy's API gateway definition
is fairly simplistic right it is look at
the Gateway this is the service it's
just a proxy to send everything in there
so alternative I've explained was last
night which is something I've been
wanting to add more pooling with and say
we make this easier to set up is what if
we use s3 to handle all of the
JavaScript and CSS so and I like this is
from my other account here
this guy's implementation you see what I
did here is I still have that proxy to
send everything to my ISO core but I
have for the CSS and the disks folder I
have a proxy that says send everything
to my s3 bucket same with this one and
so I have copied all those static
content to that one so in this case to
show what I am talking about
if we look at this is poster Shh
here is the a spinet core application
basin at the lambda function exponet
core and the demo that we've already
been doing today we look at let's just
clear these logs started scratch here
and if i refresh this now we refresh
this get the latest logs you can see we
got quite a few of the vlogs coming in
through the reason I got multiple is
because there's multiple compute
environments currently going on so we
got parallel requests and so if we look
at this so you can see see this lambda
function is being split up just to
return back to the site CSS file and
these other ones are there right so in
this other let's take a look at my other
implementation here again it's the same
code in the other one I just
re-engineered the API gateway layout so
let's go there
[Music]
and so here is this guy's lambda
function delete its logs we can see what
just happens for that get the URL from
the stack
completely left to pull veneer so this
guy now if we looked at its lambda
function at its logs see in this case we
just had two requests we had one for the
main page that's basically controlling
the base pass for angular and then just
the Web API to get the whole feeds so
there's a way you can use API gateway to
basically reduce some of it so station
record to take static content and push
that back into s3 okay so that we can
see how we can run a set of core apps on
lambda you do that with the Amazon lend
a phonetic or server nougat package
obviously poster you might not be the
easy way to just get started but you can
actually just get started in the
blueprints there is a blueprint under
project service there's an ace in our
core blueprint that has that already set
up for you and I didn't have a blog post
I put out there that walks through how
you could take an existing eight-minute
core application and deploy it this way
if you want to try that out
we also learned how we can use
confirmation to manage our whole
architecture out there for us and we
used a two step functions to define our
state machine so we can control when our
function are when our poles became
active and deactivated that some final
links for everybody
the toolkit out there again 2017 you can
get it from the gallery 15 from our
website all of the Dinoco lambda tooling
the CLI stuff the libraries I do all
that work and a gallon github on Eddy is
lambda net so if you ever have any
questions or issues on how to deal with
dotnet core and lambda feel free to open
up an issue a question there and I'm
happy to help people out
I took a snapshot of my poster code last
night and I snuck up on this repository
if you go to that repository there is
folder that has it in there and I put
the slides in there as well so if anyone
is trying to take pictures you can just
give it from there and I contribute a
lot to the ATP stat net blog so I write
a lot about net and AWS
lately been writing about a lot of
lambda and dotnet together and with that
thank you so much for coming I don't
know if you want any questions feel free
to ask no usually a sorry the question
was was when was a region constraints
when working with AWS usually with
services that have events connecting up
to each other so if it's like a lamb to
connecting up to another event those
need to be in the same region but I can
definitely have my lambda function
that's I'm going to go access buckets
and other region but you're not going to
be able to I don't think there's any
service that has events that you can
send cross region so there is I mean
Esther you do have to pay for the
getting objects out especially for small
little files though it takes a lot for
that to be significant you have to on
the question I'm sorry of what is the
cost for going to putting the cassette
account in s3 it would be the cheaper
option than having it being delivered by
lambda so
step functions the way I've always done
it and really I've only additionally
been starting to look at step functions
lately myself mostly for this demo is
your religious can be writing X unit
integration test like there's not a way
to really just run step functions like
in a local environment so the question
is about metrics and so there are
metrics the metrics are shipped off to
cloud watch I know we have lots of names
to figure things out well actually so
cloud watch is the main place to get
logs if you look at the lambda console
then actually more detailed information
that we have and I took it right now so
here is the function that we just did
has monitoring tabs and you can see some
of the metrics there and then you can go
to the cloud watch console to drive
deeper into that you know questions all
right let's call it a day all right
thank you everybody